as good news starts to come in Americans
ask what it will take to start to reopen
president from targets the w-h-o and the
staffing chaos in the administration
continues I mentioned peril this is the
Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn your online
activity should not be public protect
yourself right now and express it VPN
comm slash Ben before we get to anything
else you may have noticed the market a
little bit volatile over the past few
weeks you notice that a little bit well
maybe it would been a good idea like a
few weeks ago to have diversified into
precious metals at least a little bit
well the same thing remains true today
in a world of volatility where you can't
know what's happening next it's not a
bad idea to be diversified into at least
something that has a solid value to it
right now you shouldn't be relying just
on the market call Birch gold and
convert your traditional IRA or 401k
into a precious metals IRA if that is
something you are interested in doing if
you've not yet taken the first step of
requesting a free information can on
gold you should know this is not a
particularly complicated process British
gold will go to work make things simple
for you they will answer all of your
questions they'll have a conversation
with you and you can determine if
precious metals make sense for you there
is no obligation to have nothing to lose
to take that first step Birch gold group
has thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau again if
you had had some precious metals in your
portfolio over the last few weeks you've
been a lot better office one of the
reasons why I suggest that everybody
diversify at least a little bit into
precious metals don't wait until the
market drops again to protect your
hard-earned savings text Ben - 47 47 47
see how simple and straightforward the
move can be for you again that's been my
name - 47 47 47 and go check out my
friends over at Birch gold alrighty so
the we have some actual good news this
morning we have some bad news in the
sense that there is always a trailing
indicator of where we are on this virus
and that is the death count the death
count in New York was very high at last
night.the the death count overall in the
United States was very high yesterday
but that is because we're moving quickly
toward the peak so the death count tends
to lag the actual number of infections
that have been identified by a
significant amount of time anywhere from
a week to two weeks last night we saw
over 1,800 Americans dead over the
course of the last day which is a big
number I mean it's definitely a big
number normally in America about 7500
Americans die in a given day
so add to that 1,800 Americans although
deaths from other causes is down fairly
significantly because everybody is
staying in so nobody's dying in car
crashes for example over all right now
the United States has suffered around
13,000 deaths and virtually all of those
have accrued in the last two weeks we
have well over 400,000 cases the
majority of the cases that have been
identified or at least the vast
plurality of the cases that have been
identified have been identified in New
York 142 thousand cases identified in
New York over five thousand deaths in
New York approaching six thousand deaths
in New York so New York is indeed the
epicenter of all this followed by New
Jersey what's been kind of amazing is to
look at the contrast between say New
York and New Jersey in California
another highly populous state which to
date has still seen under five hundred
deaths in the state of California and
the lockdown orders that went into place
in California Wednesday on three four
days earlier than the lockdown orders
that went into place in New York maybe a
week earlier on the on the very outside
in places like San Francisco with all of
that said the big factor here is that
not only did California lock down very
quickly California also is much more
spacious there people are out in
suburbia people are not on top of each
other the same way they are in areas
with public transportation networks that
are used in in enormous fashion that's
why you are seeing big optics in Detroit
basically population density is a fairly
good indicator that you're going to get
a fairly large way because people are
infecting each other
meanwhile over in the UK Boris Johnson
remains in intensive care for the second
straight day he apparently is not on
ventilators he apparently is on some
sort of supplemental oxygen Johnson is
in stable condition he is breathing
without the help of ventilator according
to a government spokesperson the 55 year
old has not been diagnosed with
pneumonia but is indeed receiving oxygen
so that is the latest on Boris Johnson
now I said there was some good news and
in fact there is some very very good
news like a lot of good news actually
today I mean as good as the news can be
in the middle of a global pandemic but
the news is good so you remember that I
am a Qi model that I've been talking
about all week long I haven't talked
about the modeling and how uncertain the
modeling is and what that means for how
we get out of this and we're gonna get
to what all of the new data means for
how we get out of this how we reopen the
economy and go back to some form of life
in just a few minutes but the IMA shoe
model has been downgraded again
again so over the course of the last
five days the I am HD model from
University of Washington which is a
curved fitting model meaning what they
do is they look at all the data coming
in from different areas and then they
try and draw a curve to fit the curves
that they're seeing in other areas so as
more data comes in then they are they're
changing the their curved to fit the
data that is coming in originally
they're relying on wuhan zeta and
they're relying on italy data and it
turns out that that data was outlying
data or not properly reported in the
case of China and so they were really
overestimating what the peak would be it
looks like they were also really over
they're really under estimating how fast
the peak would arrive because it looked
as though it's taking a while for things
to build to up because it did take a
while in Italy but that's because their
hospital resource use was completely
overwhelmed so they have now downgraded
the model again the I am a cheat
University of Washington model so
remember they'd suggest anything from
100,000 to 250,000 deaths by the
beginning of August well now they are
suggesting that the total number of
deaths in the United States which they
pegged it like 93 thousand as of last
Friday and then they downgraded that to
82,000 on Monday their net they've now
dropped it dramatically again that has
now dropped to 60 thousand 415 so it is
dropped by fully one-third since Friday
and that is because the new data is
coming in now again they they were
already gearing for everybody locked
down that was one of the actual
provisions of their study the study was
was done with the assumption that
everyone's gonna lock down through the
end of May now is everybody gonna lock
down through the in May I don't know I
think that's pretty highly unlikely
considering that we are only at the
beginning of April like going for
another six weeks on this thing seems
rather uncertain but with that said the
question is why the variability in their
own model right why did the curve change
so much so either they underestimated
the impact of people locking down
meaning that people locking down really
spread the transmission rates and it's a
factor of the transmission rates not the
death rate meaning that there are only a
few factors here that could really be
impacting the number of deaths total
right there is the transmission right
meaning let's say they let's say that
you have that you hold the death rate
constant let's say the death rate is one
percent but the transmission rate is
like three times so you're going to in
fact three people so that means tons of
people get infected and tons of people
die because you've infected a lot of
people even if the death rate is the
same
for example the flu that is one
possibility another possibility is that
the death rates themselves were
overestimated meaning that the
transmission rate was that the
transmission rate was not as high as
previously thought but they thought that
more people were dying of it than we're
actually dying of it and then the third
possibility is they thought that if
people stay at home then they would
still be going out and meeting other
people but they didn't change that
factor so what that really suggests is
that either this thing is not quite as
transmissible as they had originally
supposed or the death rate based on
actual case numbers is not as high as
previously supposed and these questions
are really vital it is really important
to know the answers to these questions
because until we know the answers to
these questions we're not gonna know how
to roll out a recovery plan we're not
gonna know should we let tons of people
out because what if a huge percentage of
the population has already had this
thing what if 30% of the population has
already had this thing right as we are
seeing in New York City as the number of
tests goes up so do the number of
positives we've actually seen something
a 45 46 percent positive rate for people
who are coming in for coronavirus tests
in New York now again that's
self-selected it's not randomly selected
those are people who are coming in with
symptoms but that does suggest pretty
wide and broad spread of this thing okay
so they've also downgraded the number of
deaths per day in terms of the peak so
like three days ago they were suggesting
that the peak was going to happen I
believe the April 15th and they'd
suggested over 3,000 deaths like 3,300
deaths on that day instead they are now
projecting that the highest day of death
is going to be on April's 12 and will be
2,200 deaths which is a lot lower like a
lot lower and then it will quickly drop
off to the point where we are
experiencing double-digit deaths if this
model holds which again they've been
dropping it consistently so we hope that
they continue to drop it if this model
were to be the one that actually holds
if this were accurate then we would be
dropping into double-digit deaths by May
21st right which is very very good news
also when it comes to the resources that
are used same sort of deal they've
dramatically downgraded the number of
beds that will be needed the number of
ICU beds that they'll be needed the
number of ventilators that will be
needed remember they had been suggesting
I believe 29,000 ventilators would be
needed during peak resource use which
would be in 3 days April 11th right now
they're saying they will need sixteen
thousand five hundred ventilators right
which is a drum
decrease almost by 50% they same thing
with the with the number of total
hospital beds they drop that's 140,000
now it's done in ninety four thousand
ICU beds same sort of deal they'd said
that they would need I think it was
fifty thousand something like that ICU
beds they've dropped that down to
nineteen thousand so the models are
continually being reduced and that does
suggest that there is some data that has
entered into these models originally
that is not right now does that mean
that it was wrong to lock down no it
doesn't mean it was wrong to lock down
right now the question is gonna be how
we get out of this thing which is much
more important than was it wrong to lock
down I mean in the in the in the
presence of data that suggests the
lockdown has been super successful that
doesn't mean the lockdown was
unsuccessful we'll get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the underwear that Gracie or took
us at this very moment over the next few
weeks you are going to be spending a lot
of time allowing around I know you're
gonna be spending a lot of time in the
house and you need it comfortable
comfortable wardrobe lounge wear
underwear these are going to be your
very best friends and this is why you
need Tommy John the revolutionary lounge
where an underwear brand that is
redefining comfort they are offering you
right now twenty percent off your first
order treat yourself upgrade to a few
pairs of Tommy John underwear in the
softest most breathable fabrics you've
ever going to have for men and women my
wife loves her timing John underwear
they really are fantastic Tommy John
obsesses over every little detail and
Stitch these proprietary fabrics that
perform like nothing you've ever worn
before their underwear comes with a no
wedgie guarantee which definitely would
have helped me when I was younger they
were eliminated visible panty lines for
women their quick drive flaw has been
proven to save men over two hundred and
seventeen minutes a year I even know how
they measure that but apparently they've
got this thing pegged down to the minute
Tommy John is so confident in their
underwear if you don't love your first
pair you can get a full refund with
their best pair you'll ever wear it
where it's free guarantee Tommy John no
adjustment needed hurry on over to Tommy
John calm /ban for 20% off your first
order that is Tommy John calm so I spent
for 20% off again Tommy John calm so I
spend the best underwear you will ever
order ever own and I can pay a fortune
for him cuz you get 20% off when you
used my promo code that's Tommy John's
comm slash
Ben okay so meanwhile we are now seeing
in other good news that we are we are
not actually being overrun in mass terms
so one of the reasons to flatten the
curve was to prevent us from being
overrun was to prevent the hospitals
from being short on ventilators
rationing of ventilators Sean and ICU
beds short on medical resources and as
it turns out
now there have been hiccups in the
process because distribution is never
even or easy right if the federal
government says we're going to we're
gonna hand you a thousand ventilators
that doesn't mean they're gonna go
directly to the hospital department that
is necessary over the course of the next
24 hours I mean as we have seen with
virtually every government disaster
response there are just holdups in the
in the distribution chains this sort of
stuff is very common right so what you
saw in Puerto Rico and female of
shipping bottles over there bottles of
water and then six months later with
everybody not having water on the tarmac
there's just millions of bottles of
water that sort of stuff does happen
fairly frequently with that said the
response of the federal government
overall has been quite good here is Mike
Pence yesterday listing all the supplies
that have been delivered the New York
metro area including New Jersey just in
the last five days more than six million
n95 masks more than six million surgical
masks and 2.8 million gowns were
distributed to that region as well going
next to New Orleans some eight hundred
and thirty seven thousand n95 masks for
health care workers 165 surgical masks
other items including almost 6 million
gloves have been distributed just in the
last five days 1.6 million n95 masks
have been routed into the health care
system in Detroit nearly 700,000
surgical masks and in 24 million gloves
just as a portion of what's displayed
guides by the way remember ventilators
ventilators ventilators ventilators it
turns out that on Monday night both
Cuomo and Bill de Blasio claimed that
the need had been met for ventilators in
the state so there's all this talk about
ventilators and how we were going to be
splitting ventilators and rationing
ventilation that may still happen in
particular areas if those areas I see
sudden spikes for example and they've
not been distributed but gavin newsom in
california has announced that he's been
working with state governments all over
the place to purchase on massive
ventilators the United States government
is supposed to be developing a hundred
thousand ventilators that's gonna be way
more than we need like way way way more
than we that should go in the federal
stockpile that's a good thing by the way
it's not a bit just like we have lots of
nuclear weapons we never have to use
better we should have too many
ventilators on hand and then we never
have to use them then then we have too
few ventilators with that said all of
the panic talked about how we were going
to run short on ventilators the
government response was was fairly
decent here and also
it turns out the estimates were way off
for how many ventilators were actually
necessary remember Trump got ripped up
and down when he suggested that when
Cuomo said he needed 30,000 to 40,000
ventilators he thought the numbers would
be a lot lower than that
turns out numbers were kind of a lot
lower than that so Trump may have been
you know engaging in evidence-free happy
talk but his actual gas was not wrong on
that one meanwhile Andrew Cuomo came out
yesterday the governor of New York he
said we have not lost a single human
being because of lack of care so for all
of the talk about you know shortages
we've responded such that people are not
dying because they're not getting the
care they need the question is are you
saving everyone you can save and there
the answer is yes and I take some solace
in that fact our health care system is
operating when I don't believe we lost a
single person because we couldn't
provide care people we lost we couldn't
save despite our best efforts okay so
that is that is good news is that we
have not been overrun right which was
that what I said yesterday God willing
we have flattened the curve such the
health care system is not overrun now
the question is what comes next
and we're hearing a constant drumbeat
out of the administration now that the
numbers were way too high right over the
course of two weeks that the numbers
were way too high in terms of what they
thought was going to happen now people
who think the lockdowns need to be quasi
permanent policy they're like well yeah
this is because of the lockdowns people
who are not pro that policy are like
well did we go too far the only way
we're gonna know that is with additional
data we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you're spending an awful lot of
time online right now hacking methods
are growing super sophisticated I'm sure
everybody is working from home without
your IT departments to protect you from
those online threats and this is why you
need a VPN I've been using a VPN myself
for years you should be using expressvpn
because it is the best online protection
possible I've been talking about
expressvpn on my show for a really long
time you know why you need to protect
your computer but expressvpn does it in
a really great way not only do they
protect all of your data so that they
are not no monetizing your data in some
weird backend way also expressvpn he's
really fast easy to use is like a slow
down your computer one of the easiest
ways to secure your internet data is
with expressive VPN one-click on your
computer smartphone you are now
protected so the question is why have
you not done this yet right this is
quick
this is easy it's not gonna cost you a
fortune visit my special link right now
and expressvpn comm so I've been get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free protect your internet today with
the VPN I trust to keep my data safe
that's expressive VPN calm slash man
again that's expr yes I VPN calm slash
pen when you use that slash man you get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free go check them out right now as I
say it is a drum beat out of the
administration now the CDC's Robert
Redfield the head of the CDC
he says the corona virus death toll is
gonna be a lot lower than we expected if
we continue to socially distance the
American public are taking the social
distancing recommendations to heart and
I think that's the direct consequence
while you're seeing the numbers are
going to be much much much much lower
ain't not only that doctor foul she came
out he says by next week we're gonna be
looking at the downside of the slope
here is doctor pouch yesterday as we get
it further on beyond this week we should
start to see the beginning of a
turnaround which is a good sign so you
know it's very sobering to see the
increase in deaths and we predicted over
the weekend that this would really be a
bad week and it is it's gonna be a bad
week for deaths but driving that and
ahead of that is the fact that we're
gonna start to see the beginning of a
turnaround so we need to keep pushing on
the mitigation strategies because
there's no doubt that that's having a
positive impact on the dynamics of the
outbreak
now she also suggested one of the
original models projected a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousand deaths
as we are getting more data and seeing
the positive effects of mitigation those
numbers are going to be downgraded right
now it's gonna be a lot less than the
original projection once again is really
good it does raise the question of I
thought that your models originally took
into account the fact that we were
socially distancing so that means
another one of the other factors changed
right because if your model right if
their own there's only XY and Z if X was
the the factor of social distancing and
if that remained constant then the model
could only change with Y or Z
transmission rate or death rate Raymond
those are the only factors in the model
they're not a lot of other factors in
the model since everybody is staying
home unless you know presumably for some
reason you thought that the staying home
was not going to mitigate this thing
nearly as much like you assumed that 50%
of the population was going to stay home
and it turned out to be a hundred
percent of the population but they have
not really
said that yet and you dub model doesn't
suggest that the University of
Washington model so exactly what comes
next how do we get out of this well Rama
Rama Manuel's brother is he killed me
Ezekiel Manos brother I believe so
Ezekiel Emanuel who is a healthcare
policy expert one of the Obamacare minds
yesterday he gave his dark vision he
said there will be no religious services
or dinner in restaurants for 12 to 18
months here he was yesterday basically
saying we're gonna have to continue to
tamp down the economy until we find a
vaccine which could take upwards of a
year
realistically kovat 19 will be here for
the next 18 months or more we will not
be able to return to normalcy until we
find a vaccine or effective medications
if we prematurely end that physical
distancing and the other measures
keeping it at bay deaths could skyrocket
into the hundreds of thousands if not a
million we cannot return to normal until
there's a vaccine conferences concerts
sporting events religious services
dinner in a restaurant none of that will
resume until we find a vaccine a
treatment or a cure okay so it may be
true that that is the case but we're
gonna have to look at how other
countries are handling this and also we
are going to have to get better
statistics on how all of this works
because there are really three questions
that need to be asked first what is the
true coronavirus fatality rate that
question is really important because it
determines whether certain areas ought
to be open or closed whether we ought to
pursue in Sweden style a more
liberalized Society that presumes a very
wide spread so for example if we have
wide spread already and it is impossible
to tamp it down such that we can
actually socially trace and and contact
trace
well then presumably we'd be better off
just telling everybody whose most
vulnerable stay home work from home and
telling everybody else go out and get it
right give each other right that that's
kinda what Sweden is doing and right now
I've been very honestly perturbed by the
media coverage of what's happening in
Sweden because Sweden assumed that there
would be an uptick in deaths before
there was a downtick man I talked about
this yesterday the second wave is the
question nobody's asked me right now
okay so we flattened the curve we got it
underneath the the medical necessities
right well presumably if there's a
second wave we're not going to max out
our supply chains great now what what
happens when there's a second wave so if
all you've done by flattened
the curve is avoided some of the
hospital overruns which is great but
then there's a second wave and
everybody's gonna get it anyway
you know if the assumption is
everybody's gonna get it anyway then you
have to ask okay so what how long are we
holding this down here when people look
at Sweden and they say well they have a
bigger first wave the question is okay
but the models don't end in August I can
cite that u-dub model until the cows
come home that I am a Qi model that
model ends August August 4th this thing
ain't gonna end August 4 if we've been
told it's seasonal which means it's
coming back in the fall so what exactly
are we gonna do when it comes back in
the fall locked down again for another
what entire winter lockdown until the
vaccine is found and presumably January
or February at the very earliest and
then produced in March gonna lock down
all the way from September to March who
thinks that's gonna be a thing we've
already lost 30 million jobs who thinks
who thinks that's gonna be a thing ok so
we need to find out what the true
coronavirus fatality rate is now we've
seen the case fatality rates but those
are not super accurate right the reason
that they are not super accurate is
because the case fatality rates presume
that we know how many people have been
infected which is not correct we don't
know how many people have been infected
we don't actually even know how many
people are dead right this is one of the
problems so right now there's an
argument going on as to whether the
numerator in the fatality rate or the
denominator or both are flawed we know
for sure that the denominator is flawed
we know for sure there are lots more
people who have corona virus than have
been tested for corona virus and
confirmed to have corn virus right we
know that for a fact and as we'll
discuss in a second people are now
developing tests as they should be doing
in order to in order to get to the point
where we know the answer to that
question but as to that first question
it's now become a hot topic on Twitter
whether we're over counting Cova deaths
the theory that we are over counting
Cova deaths is that if you die having
kovat that doesn't necessarily mean you
died from kovat so if you're old and
you're 85 and and you get the flu but
you died from heart disease heart
failure or something does that mean the
unite of the flu or with the flu now is
it true that we may be over broadly
characterizing characterizing Cova
deaths by some it's possible I mean dr.
Burks did say yesterday that anyone who
died with kovat is measured as a kovat
victim as we'll see in a second it's
also I think more significantly possible
that we are under counting Cova deaths
at this point but here is dr. Burks
talking about how we are categorizing
Cova deaths there are other kind
trees that if you had a pre-existing
condition and let's say the virus called
you to go to the ICU and then have a
heart or kidney problem some countries
are recording that as a heart issue or a
kidney issue and not a covin 19 death
right now we're still recording it and
we all I mean the great thing about
having forms that come in and a form
that has the ability to mark it as
covert 19 infection the intent is right
now that those if someone dies with
kovat 19 we are counting that as a cope
at 19 death
okay so people have been citing this to
suggest that our accounts is too high
because some countries are not
categorizing these things that way
however as we'll see in a second there's
also some pretty good evidence that
accounts actually may be significantly
low we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about how long it
takes to see a doctor in normal
circumstances forget about circumstances
now where you really can't see a doctor
in in a lot of cases well what if you
are suffering from a lifestyle thing
that really is a problem for you but
it's not Kovan 19 let's say what what if
what if you are suffering from erectile
dysfunction you need to get that solved
or you've got hair loss or cold sores
and you want treatment ASAP well this is
why our friends over at Roman have spent
years building a digital platform that
can connect you with a doctor licensed
in your state all from the comfort of
home Roman makes it convenient to get
the treatment you need on your schedule
you just grab your phone or computer you
complete a free online visit and you'll
hear back from us licensed physician
within 24 hours if the doctor decides
the treatment is right for you Romans
pharmacy can ship your medication to you
with free two-day shipping you also get
free unlimited follow-ups with your
doctor anytime you have questions or you
want to adjust that treatment plan with
Roman there are no commitments you can
cancel anytime so if you've been
struggling with eg hair loss cold sores
other issues go to get Roman comm / Ben
for that free online visit and free
two-day shipping that's get Roman comm
/ban for that free online visit and free
today shipping no reason for your
suffered with the medical problem while
I was sitting at home for a month
instead why don't just go get that
telehealth equipment with get Roman and
then get the medication you need get
Roman comm / rang get that free online
visit and free two-day shipping as well
okay so the counter evidence to the idea
that we are under counting deaths comes
courtesy of Gothamist they suggest that
there are a lot
people dying at home now the city is
reversed the city of New York is
reversing its position and we'll
probably start counting Cova deaths at
home in addition to confirmed ones which
will increase the count originally
Gotham has had suggested that if you die
at home and they say it was probably
covered that was not being included in
the city counts now they are changing
that in a statement Stephanie Buell
spokeswoman for the New York City Health
Department said the city would no longer
report only cases that were confirmed by
lab tests
she said the office of chief medical
commissioner and NYC health department
are working together to include in their
report
deaths that may be linked to Colvin but
not lab confirmed that occur at home
that the new protocol is likely to add
thousands of people to the toll that
announcement came after New York saw the
largest single-day of deaths so far from
kovat 727 people died in a 24 hour
period but that didn't include many of
the cases in which first responders
encountered someone who had already died
at home or non hospital settings
apparently that happened 280 times on
Monday according to data from the fire
department which means that the total
number of deaths would presumably be
well over more about about or well over
a thousand deaths in New York City so
apparently over the last two weeks New
York Fire Department officials said that
over 2,000 New York City residents died
in their homes 2192 compared to 453
during the same time period last year on
Tuesday evening the city reported that
three thousand five hundred forty-four
people have died of coronavirus so if
you're actually to include the increase
in count then you'd be looking at
additional 1,600 over five thousand
people dead in New York City alone so as
I say the evidence seems better that we
are under Counting Cova deaths right now
then over counting those covet deaths
but bottom line is we don't actually
know the numerator in the fatality rate
right now which brings us to the
denominator
okay the denominator is the really big
one because the numerator may change but
it's not gonna change my orders of
magnitude it's not gonna be as though
there were 13,000 deaths in the United
States now there are 130,000 deaths
because we counted wrong well you may
end up with 13,000 deaths in the United
States and maybe there are 15,000 deaths
in the United States it's the
denominator that matters and the reason
the denominator matters is because
number one it gives you a better
indicator of exactly what your chances
are of dying if you actually obtain this
thing which makes a big difference in
sort of risk assessment like if you tell
me right now that if I walked outside
there's one point four percent shot then
I'm gonna be hit by a car and
I I'll probably stay inside if you tell
me that there is a 1 in 10,000 shot that
if I get hit by a car I'm gonna walk
outside gate by a car and I I'll
probably walk out the front door right
so it really depends on on the
denominator here we don't know what the
denominator is
right now and this is where some people
are working hard to put together numbers
on the denominator so there's several
different efforts that are being put
forward along these lines according to
science magazine there is an attempt by
the World Health Organization called
solidarity to to put together CRO
surveys studies that look for antibodies
to Cova to in the population the United
States is also launching unprecedented
efforts 1-0 surveys already underway in
six metropolitan areas including New
York City the hardest hit city in the
United States a second even larger one
is on its heels together they should
give a strong nationwide effort to track
closely how many Americans have become
infected as the pandemic unfolds SERO
surveys may also help efforts to develop
vaccines and separately attempts to
devise therapies to stop the virus from
causing harm scientists talk to Michael
Bush a transfusion specialist based at
UCSF and he suggests that this is
actually pretty important because once
we have serologic testing then we are
going to have to then we'll know the
numbers better yeah so so this is a very
good thing
meanwhile we are we are learning that
that there are certain people who are
really attempting to promote promote 0
surveys and new information about how we
get these antibody tests so Andrew Cuomo
governor of New York he says we've
actually developed an antibody test and
we are starting to roll that out there's
a very good thing New York State
developed a Department of Health
developed an antibody testing regimen
that Department of Health has approved
for use in New York State this tests the
blood to determine whether or not you
have the antibodies which means you had
the virus and resolved the virus that's
why you would have the antibodies for
the virus that would mean that you're no
longer contagious and you can't catch
the virus because
you have the antibodies in your system
which means you can get to work you can
go back to school you can do whatever
you want and so the the question is what
are we gonna do it the antibody test
there's been a couple of questions about
what exactly the antibody tests are for
one of those questions is are we going
to basically create a certificate that
says you can go back to work at this
point if so is that sort of a
discriminatory model is one of the
questions and is that really practical
and we don't even know at this point
whether the immunity lasts for very long
so it's possible that the immunity lasts
for six months and then you get it again
in September right people get the flu
every year sometimes because the strains
are constantly changing with that said
the antibody tests are useful for a
broader reason and that is we must know
exactly how many people in the
population have had this thing so that
we can tell what the best policy will be
so David Neil Elman is the founder of
JetBlue and as well Airways and he has a
piece over a daily wire that's pretty
important he writes thanks to the work
of three Stanford University professors
and recently fda-approved antibody tests
we will soon finally know the real size
of the denominator of all of those
infected bykova 19 and that could be the
game changer we need the denominator is
the total number of people who have been
exposed to the virus many of whom never
knew they even had it the numerator
tragically is the total number of people
who have died from the disease divide
the numerator into the denominator we
get the death or case fatality rate as
the founder of several airlines in four
countries my company in our industry
have been particularly hard-hit by the
spread of Kovan 19 since the outbreak I
spent all my days and a lot of my nights
trying to find a solution to save as
many as possible of the 40,000 jobs for
which I'm responsible and do what I can
to help avoid an economic catastrophe in
the making my search for a solution
rights rights David Newman my search for
a solution has led me to three amazing
and dedicated professors and scientists
from Stanford University School of
Medicine with impeccable credentials
I've come to know them personally
doctors John Unitas hiya not us J
Bhattacharya and Aaron Ben dahveed using
their epidemiology models and other
evidence from China Italy Iceland in the
US have question from the beginning the
true number of those who have been
infected by Kove in nineteen I've talked
to Jay about Acharya before on the radio
show everyone agrees that the number of
confirmed cases reported is not a
correct value for the total number of
infected but by how much
recent research says that up to 50% of
those infected are asymptomatic and of
the remaining 50% 80% have mild symptoms
and are unlikely to have been tested
this creates a confirmation bias because
we're only testing for people with the
more with the most severe symptoms
Unitas Bhattacharya and Ben's ovide
believe that the actual number of cases
is very likely off by an order of the
magnitude of ten or maybe even times
many more so why is this important well
as of today the u.s. is approaching
400,000 confirmed cases of Kovan 19 and
more than 10,000 deaths what if the
Stanford doctors are right when the
actual numbers of those infected is
actually 3 million or 10 million it
would be a game-changer enough right
against the virus if it could be proven
that 20 or 30 percent of New Yorkers
were actually infected instead of less
than 1% it would tell us that the peak
is closer than we think and most
important the case fatality rate would
be a tiny fraction of the percentage
based on deaths as a fraction of
confirmed cases most important this
information would provide governor's
mayors and public health officials
valuable new data in determining the
number of ICU beds that might be
required as of yesterday New York had
4,000 patients and ICU beds Governor
Cuomo rightly believes that he could
need 30,000 ICU beds at the peak of the
epidemic with less than 1% of the
population with confirmed cases but if
the actual number of people infected is
much higher then you'd need far fewer
ICU beds but now the FDA has approved
this quick test and while caution should
be taken in relying on these tests
they're more than sufficient for
determining the correct denominator from
a population sample so bhattacharya and
ped Naveed have started a study in santa
clara county in california using
antibody tests they've assembled a team
that collected 2,500 blood samples over
2 days once they have the results
they're gonna compare those who test
positive for the antibodies with the
number of confirmed cases and give them
scientific information that could
predict better how many people actually
have this also unspoken is the reality
which is that have tons and tons of
people have this then the idea of of
widespread testing and contact tracing
is probably not the best solution
especially because again everybody is
asymptomatic so unless you're willing to
put down tens of millions of tests every
week and then quarantine people and
socially track them then perhaps the
best case scenario is the is the sort of
Sweden scenario where we take everybody
whose most vulnerable we tell them stay
home and everybody else goes back out to
work right that could very well be what
we are talking about right here again
because nobody knows what that second
wave looks like in the fall right that
is the the second question to be asked
right one is case fatality right one is
the second wave and what exactly that
looks like and then finally what exactly
can we do here because once we've
established the case fatality rate we
still have to figure out what does the
second wave look like and can it even be
doctor foul she says we're gonna be in
good shape to open the schools in the
fall which is kind of an interesting
take from from dr. Fatih here he was
explaining that schools might be
reopened I fully expect though I'm
humble enough to know that I can't
accurately predict that by the time we
get to the fall that we will have this
under control enough that it certainly
will not be the way it is now where
people are shutting schools my
optimistic side tells me that we'll be
able to renew to a certain extent but
it's gonna be different so that is you
know that is good news but it does raise
the question okay so let's say all these
kids go to school and then they come
home and grandpa and grandma are there
like are they all gonna get infected and
found you didn't answer that question so
presumably what we're gonna I think in
the end we're gonna end up with a quick
and dirty policy right there's a lot of
talk about widespread testing and
national coronavirus surveillance
systems well if you already have
community spread and if it turns out
that as people suspect far more people
are infected than we currently think
well then what you're gonna end up with
is there's nothing we can do about
community infection it's already out
there the case fatality rate is low we
have tremendous amounts of medical
resources that have now been made
available the things I'd offer for the
summer prepare for the second wave and
people who are most vulnerable need to
stay home I think that's probably where
we end up in terms of practical policy
and in terms of the economy that
probably is not the the worst thing
right again this is why we need more
data data data data data right it sounds
a lot better than I mean there should be
real unease over the fact that there are
so many people who are looking out to
create a national coronavirus virus
surveillance system like I don't know
what know what that's gonna look like I
mean if you weren't worried about the
invasion of privacy that was attendant
on 9/11 then I think that we should be a
little bit worried about the invasion of
privacy that is attendant on we're going
to surveil you everywhere you go if you
test positive for coronavirus or if you
have a fever right because again these
tests they're like the dirty little
secret here is that the coronavirus
tests are not supremely accurate like 20
percent of people who are testing for
this thing negative are actually
positive for coronavirus they're not
supremely accurate at this point okay so
I was going to get two more on
coronavirus and perhaps we still will
but I would be remiss if I did not point
out that in breaking news Bernie Sanders
has dropped out of the race so that is a
thing that has now happened brilliant
brilliant
that that Bernie Sanders waited until
after that Wisconsin primary like the
day after the Wisconsin primary where it
was obvious who's gonna getcha lacked
any way to drop out so lots of people
waited in line thanks to dramatic
confusion over what should be done
during a primary during the Cova
nineteen era and then Bernie got out so
just adding insult to injury he waits
until after everybody stands in line to
vote for him in Wisconsin and then he
gets out of the race
he's gonna give some sort of statement
but putting for everybody I think is the
short statement every boat that gets
pulled in goodbye pony well sue later I
mean good good I mean Cuba hardest hit
the Castro's hardest hit Venezuela
hardest hit how terrible how terrible
the Bernie that Bernie is out I really
don't have much more than that like I'm
it was it was an obvious thing like the
only reason he was staying in presumably
was to gets 25% of the delegate base and
then he could use that authority to kind
of throw his weight around at the
convention he could still try to do that
he could still walk into the convention
and say that I'm not gonna throw my
Bernie Sanders supporters behind you Joe
Biden unless you do XY and Z so I don't
think that he needed the formal delegate
count in order to do that with that said
he doesn't have a lot of weight now and
Joe Biden would be a fool to start
catering to the Bernie Sanders side of
the party he's got to count on the fact
that people don't like Trump to unify
the party not on catering to the Bernie
Sanders IDEs because right now Biden's
entire campaign rests on the feeling
that he is not volatile that he is not
radical that he is non-threatening right
that's the stuff where people are
worried about Bernie Sanders
so Biden starts catering to that he
actually undercuts his own message okay
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first we are proud to associate
with businesses that focus on the needs
of our audience like bull and branch
they are fantastic partners measured by
the quality of their products and the
way they pursue your satisfaction bull
and branch epitomizes an American
business success story they don't just
make sheets and bedding pillows towels
all the kinds of comfortable things that
you need in your home with your help
they put thousands of people to work
around the world from their pillows made
in Cincinnati Ohio to their mattresses
made in Florida Texas in Arizona since
they started six years ago my bull and
branch eats great example of something
small I treat myself to that really
makes a huge difference in fact the ball
and bran sheets are so good I literally
cannot sleep on other sheets now I mean
it's ruined other sheets for me they're
so good in times like these when we're
spending a lot of time at home starting
and ending your day on the Bowlin branch
sheets and pillows is great
minder that life can still be good and
that it's gonna be even better just a
few weeks from now thanks to being
available online bull and branch comm is
indeed open for business they are still
shipping their sheets pillows and more
fast and free anywhere in the United
States if you've never tried their stuff
it's gonna blow you away like I when I
first heard a bull and ranch like really
can I shoot make that big of difference
yes yes it can it turns out that these
things unbelievably comfortable will
increase your sleep quality tremendously
Boleyn branch is still offering their
30-day guarantee if you don't love them
you can return for a full refund that's
how good they are remember you only find
bull and branch sheets online it's Bo Bo
LL and branch comm if now's the time to
make such a purchase
use code ben shapiro get fifty bucks off
your first set of sheets which is a
great deal shipping is fast and free
restrictions may apply see bull and
branch comm for details they're great
advertiser n it's a great product bol oh
and branch comm check them out right now
and use code ben shapiro
to get fifty bucks off ok we'll get some
more in the breaking news side of the
business in a second first if you have
not yet had a chance to see some of our
new content called all-access lab you
should head over to daily wire.com and
check it out
Jeremy boring and I kicked it off a few
weeks ago all the other hosted live
streams over its daily wire we've been
continuing all this week at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific yesterday I did
the all-access live and I actually wore
a t-shirt I know I know it's an actual
thing I wore a t-shirt the show is
intended for our all-access members
during this national emergency and the
time of isolation we've opened it up to
everybody and we've accelerated the
launch so please let us know what you
think of it if you're around at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. pacific tonight join us
on the all-access live show over at
daily wire.com we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say the breaking news that
Bernie Sanders has indeed dropped out of
the presidential race according to NBC
News the Vermont independent senators
2020 bid started off strong he narrowly
missed first place in Iowa before
picking up wins in New Hampshire and
Nevada all the while his campaign
continued to rake in millions and smalls
all our donations and PAC rallies full
of supporters as he ascended to national
frontrunner status amid a crowded
Democratic field in 2020 a number of
candidates backed policies similar to
his own but in the end he ended up
falling when the rest of the party
basically united against him because he
was just too radical his campaign
officially stalled in South Carolina
fueled by a critical endorsement from
representative james Clyburn Biden won
the Palmetto State decisively and then
the moderate wing of the party
consolidated around him Warren dropped
out of the race after Super Tuesday she
declined to endorse any candidate a week
later on March 10th Biden dominated in
five of the six states that voted
including Michigan one of Sanders his
biggest to 2016 victories to grow his
delegate lead over the Vermont senator
and then he lost brutally in Florida
Illinois in Arizona on March 17th a day
after the contests with the next voting
nights and weeks away Sanders campaign
manager brought the Canada was gonna be
having conversations about moving
forward now he has decided not to move
forward presumably he's gonna blame the
lack of moving forward on kovat he's
gonna say if it weren't for kovat I
would have still been able to hold my
rallies and I would have been able to
get you all out to vote and
non-socialist
never has a socialist agenda been more
popular or more necessary and people
going me like yeah Bernie going which is
how people have felt for it several
weeks at this point so we've been a non
fond farewell to Bernie Sanders we don't
have the USSR anthem on hand if we did
we'd be playing it in salute to the
geriatric communist okay meanwhile as I
say back to the actual stuff that
matters when it comes to how we get out
of this thing some suggestions have been
early on suggested that we needed to
move from China to South Korea right
that that meant like contact tracing and
heavy testing that all depends on the
denominator if it turns out that not a
lot of people have had kovat yet that's
gonna be what we have to do right we
locked it down to the point where
basically the cases are close to zero
and then we can start widespread testing
if somebody gets it we lock them down we
contact trace them if however the
denominator is really large if it turns
out that tons of people have this and
tons of people who are asymptomatic have
this then contact tracing is not going
to be useful anymore because just there
are too many people out there to trace
all of them so we have to that's why the
data
I keep focusing on the data because the
data really are the key here the data
are what manner it meanwhile White House
senior adviser Jared Kushner has created
a task force reaching out to a range of
health technology companies about
creating a national coronavirus
surveillance system to give the
government a near real-time view of
where patients are seeking treatment and
for what
whether hospitals can accommodate them
according to for people with knowledge
of the discussions now that's a good
thing I mean you want to know which
hospitals are being overrun and need
supplies
but the question is whether the federal
government is basically going to start
monitoring every citizen in the country
for kovat health privacy laws grant
broad exceptions for national security
purposes but the prospect of compiling a
national database of potentially
sensitive health information has
prompted concerns about civil liberties
which presumably it should I mean these
these should be open debates jessica
rich former director of the Federal
Trade Commission's at Consumer
Protection Bureau says this is a genuine
crisis we have to work through it and do
our best to protect people's health
doing that doesn't mean we have to
destroy privacy okay so bottom line here
is that everyone is struggling to figure
out exactly how reopening happens this
is true broad to Denmark is trying to
figure out how they reopen Italy is
trying to figure out how they reopen
China has been reopening but only sort
of and meanwhile you know all their
propaganda is being echoed by the media
they're still presumably death in China
from all of this I will say points to
the troll crew over in China the
People's Republic of China released a
video last night about enjoying food in
Wuhan not kidding you it's like well up
the balls on those people I mean it was
like come enjoy our food and Moo Han I
think it was people enjoying the food
and who had a little too much that led
to you know the worst crisis in the
history of humanity in some ways in any
case in wil hen it's now becoming clear
that the battle is far from over
according to The Wall Street Journal the
city has announced only three confirmed
cases since March 18th which is a lie
authorities have ended the 70s a seven
day lockdown on the city allowing
inbound and outbound traveled for
healthy people after eating some
residential restrictions to revive the
crippled local economy but now they've
been tightening restrictions on some
housing complexes they've said others
will remain in place after confirming
dozens of new asymptomatic cases and
that's the big problem is the
asymptomatic cases unless you're gonna
have tons and tons and tons of people
testing every single day asymptomatic
cases are gonna arrive and presumably
everybody is going to infect each other
again so that is why once again the
apparently the study that's being done
the serology tests there being on the
antibody test they're being done like
Santa Clara County and all this those
will be available on Friday I am
fascinated to learn what the actual
numbers are in the denominator because
the fact is we cannot continue this way
as an economy we cannot continue this
way in terms of lifestyle the American
people are not going to sit home for the
next year it's not going to happen now
maybe they go to restaurants and they
socially a distance maybe we don't go to
ballgames
but if you think that people are going
to be walked in their home with their
children for a year not going to school
good luck charlie that is not happening
meanwhile we are already seeing the
small business aid program stretched to
its limits because the amount of money
that is pouring through the fire hose
the the nozzle on the fire hose just is
not wide enough and Congress is weighing
adding more than 250 billion dollars
more to small business aid to keep those
businesses alive
meanwhile a third of us apartment
renters didn't bother to pay their April
rent there's a patchwork of federal and
local laws preventing eviction right now
those laws are getting extraordinary in
places like California almost all
California foreclosures and evictions
have now been put on hold for the
foreseeable future
the state's new Judicial Council on
Monday issued emergency orders that
stopped lenders efforts to foreclose on
mortgages and landlords ability to evict
tenants except in cases where public
health or safety are involved also the
governor has issued edicts which
includes stiff limitations on lender
foreclosures and tenant evictions and
now they are putting I mean it is
putting property owners and banks at
financial risk because not only are they
suggesting that they are going to push
off the evictions not only that they are
also suggesting that they're going to
allow people not to be evicted for a
full 90 days beyond the term of the
national emergency so once the national
emergency is over you still get to live
in your home rent-free for three months
which is a great way to destroy all
development in the state of California
and destroy the real estate market in
the state of California Daniel you
Coulson is an apartment associations
executive director he said many see
these eviction moratoriums as carte
blanche for not paying rent and rent for
any reason well nobody wants to see
anyone that is truly impacted by the
virus put out in the streets the entire
burden for housing people in our
communities cannot merely be forced upon
the backs of private citizens which of
course is true and it's going to lead to
presumably some sort of government
bailout on that and as well the
council's rules apply for 90 days after
the state of emergency is lifted
the new rules mean borrowers and tenants
do not have to respond to legal demands
for payments during that period and the
right to fight foreclosure and evictions
are extended past the council's freeze
period which means it could be six
months people could be living in their
apartments for six months with no rent
because of the attempts that are being
made by the California government this
thing has to end in has to end forthwith
as soon as the data make it possible for
us to end it and we should be looking to
how we end this thing in the broadest
possible way as soon as the data allow
and I keep saying as soon as the data
allowed because again I'm not somebody
saying go rush out into the street go
back to work everybody enjoy your life I
don't think that's what the data show
right now but let's see what the data
show in terms of what is realistic
because what I'm hearing from a lot of
people doesn't sound very realistic to
me hundreds of millions of tests being
trotted out and people taking them
voluntarily on a daily basis you know
you being tested for coronavirus every
time you enter a restaurant what if I to
say to go to two restaurants in one day
like what what if as we say a huge
number of Americans have already had
this thing and many are immune or what
if the huge number of Americans have it
and are asymptomatic and are carrying
and there's no way to test them because
they don't even show up on tests because
the tests aren't sensitive enough right
the Wall Street Journal is pointing out
just how how crazy this is right a sharp
reduction in new infections is a
critical first step they say but health
experts say other steps will be needed
to prevent another devastating outbreak
that shuts the economy down all over
again that includes building testing and
surveillance systems and a readiness to
reintroduce social distancing and other
mitigations on smaller scale if
necessary to give businesses and
individuals confidence they can return
to work without risking infection dr.
pouchy says it's not like a light switch
on and off it's a gradual pulling back
on certain restrictions to try and get
society a bit back to normal but none of
these things are available like are we
really gonna have these tests ready in
September I mean he says we're gonna be
back to school again once things once
kids go back to school this whole thing
is over cuz kids are gonna in fact each
other they're gonna be in asymptomatic
carriers they're gonna see grandma and
grandpa that's what's gonna happen yeah
I have kids three of them under the age
of seven I was six of three and a
newborn and grandparents are over a lot
right now that's okay what happens when
they go back to school right that is the
big question and I've yet to see anybody
lay out a plan and that's why I keep
saying data data data data and then a
plan if we hit these numbers we do X if
we hit these numbers we do Y right how
about that how about some can like I
thought this is what the government is
supposed to be good at but apparently
not
okay it's time to get to some things
that I like and some things that I hate
so things that I like and I hate let's
talk about President Trump here so
President Trump said some good things
yesterday and he said some bad things
yesterday I mean this is like epic level
good Trump bad Trump and sometimes he
says stuff you're like yeah that sounds
pretty fantastic good for you and
sometimes he says stuff you're like why
are you doing this why why why why why
why is it that every other what major
Western leader has experienced a
15-point boost in the polls and
president Trump experienced like a
five-point boost in the polls and now
it's dissipated well part of that would
have to do with the fact that President
Trump has an unfortunate tendency to
take his foot and shove it all the way
down his throat sometimes he says things
that are wonderful right when he objects
to nationalization of Industry because
he has a gut-level love for America and
American business and sometimes he says
things that are super dumbass achill and
it's it's very difficult for the
American public to feel solid and stable
when he does this sort of stuff it's all
fun and games when you're on Twitter but
the middle of a global pandemic it seems
like like I had a theory for years about
Trump but basically just ignore what he
says and follow what he does in you're a
happy camper and it becomes a lot harder
when people are feeling this disquieted
and when national leadership matters
right I mean this is why they got the
Queen of England out there speaking for
only the fourth time in the last hundred
ninety years okay so anyway president
Trump said some good stuff yesterday he
said some bad stuff yesterday good stuff
that he said so first he said he'd love
to reopen the country with the big bang
now first of all I think this is good
when he says this kind of stuff the
reason I think it's good is because if
we see that politicians actually want to
keep things closed and just spend
enormous amounts of money we start to
think to ourselves maybe I shouldn't
stay home maybe this is all a scam the
fact that Trump does not obviously want
to keep people locked up is one of the
key reasons that people are staying
locked up right now because people are
like okay well at least I know that guy
doesn't actually want to just chained me
in my house and then toss me twelve
hundred bucks a month
there's president Trump yesterday saying
he'd love to reopen the country with a
big bang well I'd love to open with a
big bang one beautiful country and just
open but it's very possible so we're
looking at two concepts we're looking at
the concept we open up sections and
we're also looking at the concept where
you open up everything I think New York
is getting ready if not already but
getting ready to peek and once it peeks
it'll start coming down and then it's
going to come down fair
so that that is you know president from
as best I think providing hope to the
American people that's a good thing he
always said that he was a cheerleader
for the American people I think that's
true I think that's good other good
things the President Trump said
yesterday so he said that he is looking
withholding money to the WHI well and
indeed unless conditions change at the
WHI we should be looking at withholding
money they've become a Chinese catspaw
World Health Organization because they
really are they called it wrong they
call it wrong they really they missed
the call they could have called it
months earlier they would have known and
they should have known and they probably
did know so we'll be looking into that
very carefully and we're gonna put a
hold on money spent to the w-h-o we're
gonna put a very powerful hold on it and
we're gonna see so that is in fact a
again I think it's not a bad thing WH
has been a giant failure so according to
the according to National Review they
have an editorial over there they say
that the w-h-o started off in really
doing really great things like
eradicating smallpox and moving toward
the eradication of leprosy and river
blindness but they've really disgraced
themselves on December 30th Chinese
doctor lay when Liang warned colleagues
about the outbreak of an illness
resembling severe acute respiratory
syndrome
public health officials rely on the
acuity of doctors likely but Chinese
authorities didn't reward him they
summon him to the public security bureau
in Wuhan on accusations he'd made false
statements and disrupting the public
order
the CCP the Chinese Communist Party then
followed up with numerous other arrests
and publicly warned it would punish
anyone spreading rumors on social media
by mid-january Chinese doctors knew
kovat 19 was spreading between humans on
January 14th the who stated that there
was no clear evidence of human-to-human
transmission of corona virus two weeks
later the WHO director-general Tedrow
siddhanam Gabri guesses who's the only
non medical doctor ever to lead who flew
to Beijing from meeting with Xi Jinping
who so impressed said the Rosi loud at
Chinese authorities for setting a new
standard for outbreak control and
praised their openness for sharing
information we might have disagreed with
the sentiment but it was too late he had
already died after contracting
Kovan 19 when the WHO Emergency
Committee discussed whether to declare
kovin a public health emergency January
23rd international observers had
definitively discredited Chinese health
data but Tedros continued relying on
those data in
arguing against declaring in emergency
finally he declared an emergency on
January 30th and he continued as late as
February 20th to argue the Chinese
actions were slowing the spread of
coronavirus to the rest of the world
National Review correctly says the who
has lent its imprimatur to Chinese
disinformation and blessed China's slow
response to its domestic outbreak which
likely caused a 20-fold increase in
cases according to a University of
Southampton study so good for Trump for
for putting the screws to the who it
definitely deserves it and president
Trump also was right to point out in his
press conference yesterday that Joe
Biden has changed his position on the
travel ban the media basically just
glossed right over that the Joe Biden
had completely flipped on the travel ban
from China one thing with the Joe Biden
that I respect on Friday he issued a
statement that he thought I was right on
closing the border to China so I respect
the fact that he was able to do that you
know he took the opposite view and then
he was able to do that so I thought that
was actually I thought that was very
nice okay so all of that is all of that
is fine and the subtweet of a Biden
there they be kind of the subtle knife
between theirs all of that is fine then
there is the bad room and again this has
been pretty epic good Trump antrum so
yesterday during his press conference
Trump talked about how well he gets
along with Andrew Cuomo who he has been
in sort of a tete-a-tete match with and
then he talked about also some
government governor's are bad they're
acting like political animals there
they're really bad again like this none
of this is useful none of this is useful
like steady leadership would be very
good at a time like this and in terms of
action the leadership has been fairly
steady I mean as steady as it can be in
the midst of an unprecedented global
pandemic but when the president says
this kind of stuff it's just not useful
I think we've gotten along very well
with Andrew and most of the governor's I
mean a couple I could tell you were
wouldn't matter what you did you could
give them 10 times more than they asked
if the if the newspapers called and
wanted a quote they'd give you a bad
quote because that's the way they are
you know their political animals and
it's you know this is beyond politics
what we've been going through here like
the constant feeling of war world war
from from is actually not useful like
he'd have a leg to stand on when he says
we need to unite in the face of this if
again he worried more Uniting figure
meanwhile there's a continued chaos
inside the administration the top leader
of the Navy
had to step down after the after he went
aboard a ship and proceeded to rail
against a Navy captain who had been
fired for sending out a a missive
talking about how the aircraft carrier
needed basically to be docked according
to political an aircraft carrier
sidelined by a chronal virus outbreak a
promising captain fired for requesting
help as infections spread among his
5,000 sailors a service leaders list
once more after the acting Navy
secretary resigned Tuesday following an
uproar over a profanity-laced address to
the ship's crew the Navy has weathered
its share of crises and in the past few
months saw the previous Navy secretary
forced out over his handling of a war
crimes case and the man selected to be
its top Admiral instead retired due to
an improper professional relationship
with a former staffer accused of making
unwanted sexual advances to several
women but the resignation of secretary
Thomas Mosely leaves the service
lurching in the middle of a pandemic I
mean it's just it was bad stuff
basically there there was the sky Bret
Crozier we talked about this the the
captain who had blasted out an email to
Navy personnel who were not in the chain
of command asking for aid and suggesting
that the carrier needed to be docked and
the head of the Navy then proceeded to
visit the ship and he called the Croesus
actions naive and stupid and ripped into
the guy over the loudspeakers on the
ship and then he was forced to resigned
so just again that that is not a good
look also not a good look the president
has now removed the independent watchdog
for coronavirus funds now I am a member
of the crowd that believes in the
unitary executive branch I don't believe
that there should be quote unquote
independent inspectors inside the
executive branch this is what the
legislature is for if the legislature
wants to set up its own Legislative
Council to oversee spending then it can
absolutely do that in legislation I can
absolutely haul in the Trump
administration with all of their reports
and go through it that's why you have an
oversight committee for example to
oversee things right that's what the
Oversight Committee is for instead there
are these random sort of inspectors it's
general all over the executive branch
and this creates an unaccountable third
well fourth branch of government that
that is not accountable to the president
really cuz if he fires them there's all
sorts of hubbub and also not really
accountable to the legislature because
the legislature is not in a position to
fire them either well with all of that
said it's not a great look when
President Trump fired
Glenn fine the acting Pentagon watchdog
he he'd been charged
lead a group to oversee the
implementation of the coronavirus law on
Monday Trump removed fine from his post
instead he named the EPA inspector
general to serve as the temporary
Pentagon watchdog in addition to his
other responsibilities that decision
effectively removed fine from his role
overseeing the coronavirus relief effort
since the new law permits only current
inspectors general to fill the position
apparently fine will go back to his
Senate confirmed post as principal
Deputy Inspector General of the Pentagon
there have been questions raised by
senator Lamar Alexander for example
saying like I'm not sure why he did this
but that's not a great look also this
comes directly on the heels of from
going after an HHS watchdog after they
reported on hospital shortages right
President Trump the other day like
directly went after this IG report he
tweeted out why didn't the IG who spent
eight years with the Obama
administration did she report on the
failed h1n1 swine flu debacle where
17,000 people died wants to talk to
Admirals generals VP and others in
charge before doing her report another
fake dossier the feeling of people are
out to get me again nobody cares about
that stuff right now nobody cares about
that stuff right now what we care about
is that the resources get where they're
going they have by and large been
getting where they are going and we want
to make sure that we're not wasting all
of our money and we need a better reason
than I don't like the guy for firing an
Inspector General inside the government
especially at this time already so that
is those are things that I like as well
as hate we have run out of time
unfortunately but we will be back here
let's see when two hours later today and
then we will be acting on Monday because
it's Passover tonight so that means so
everybody who is Jewish
enjoy your Seder be at home with your
family if you want to see the the
plagues just walk outside and take a
look around and and then we will be back
here at the following Monday we do have
a Sunday special episode that is going
to be coming out with a featuring for
Eastern Franklin Graham so go check that
out for sure
otherwise hang in there we'll bring you
all the data all the updates come Monday
will also be here we can all pray that
we will be and in the meantime hunker
down with your family and enjoy a couple
hours of this later today or just hang
out with our other shows don't worry
we'll be hanging all my friends we'll be
hanging out with you the rest of the
week all my friends and Noel's they'll
be hanging out with you the rest of week
over a daily where to go check it out
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the ben
shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20/20 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]